magnifique christine deviers-joncour cdu
quoi ça du lapin à le portugal pas
c'est la partie a servi pour faire la
petite veste comment ça va eh ben ça va
pas mal christine deviers-joncour dont
on vous a connu [ __ ] de la république
est les saillies on vous a connu
chanteuse et maintenant vous êtes
écrivain non mais je crie 85e oui mais
la suite à nantes on essaie de sa
romance
est vraiment les autres c'était pour les
affaires au moins un outil complet pour
me défendre une battre là on souffle on
parle d'autre chose on parle en mal au
cul on parle de cul de la vraie vie oui
christine vous êtes une vraie touche à
tout
alors avant de passer aux livres qui
vous amène que le signe de v gens
courent on va quand même faire le point
sur les activités
précédentes donc [ __ ] de la république
effectivement vous regrettez d'ailleurs
et vous le dit assez souvent de ne pas
avoir intitulé le livre [ __ ] de
république oui mais [ __ ] ou les
maquereaux de république j'ai eu tort
bien alors ensuite christine on vous a
connu chanteuse et là on a découvert
avec stupeur monde la sortie du disque
que toute votre enfance deviez
travailler le piano avec un grand
musicien espagnol qui avait fui le
franquisme qui s'était réfugié à sarlat
et que normalement vous auriez dû être
christine deviers-joncour chef
d'orchestre compositeur
voilà comme bénin fini sa carrière elle
a toujours mené les âmes à la baguette
de toute façon
au pc jaunisse la jebba qui a mené la
vie dure
à la baguette c'est dur de commencer à
55 ans pour une jeune chanteuse pourquoi
vous dites mon âge je dîne mieux
manager vous êtes en avoir tes poils
blancs n'étaient pas de la première
[Applaudissements]
vous pensez à quoi vous pensez quoi
sérieusement question vous pensez quoi
de ces nouveaux chanteurs qui ne savent
pas chanter qui vendent des millions
d'albums alors que vous entendez
beaucoup moins vous savez pas chanter en
plus
c'était pas je ne sais pas chanter je
crois que d'abord j'ai eu envie de
décrire c'est une sage m'exprimer c'est
ce qui m'a motivé en même temps la
musique j'ai toujours baigné est bon si
ça marche ça marche moi je me fais
plaisir c'est le principal ne croyez pas
vous auriez dû chanter pour ceux qui
sont loin de chez eux qu'ils ont dans
les yeux quelque chose qui fait mal
je pense vous regretté de pas avoir
écrit votre chance en vous même mais je
les écris moi même mais ça tu regrettes
pas
ça pas écouté l'album si je devais dire
après je les écoute deux fois pas mais
ne riez pas sorti basque alors donc
[ __ ] la république deux chanteuses
trois écrivains
un livre après un disque que vous voulez
vraiment retourné en prison christine
non parce que là j'ai ris coréen pas
cela qu'on parle pas d' affaire d'état
par rapport à votre place si vous auriez
pas mieux fait de sortir une ligne de
chaussures non
ça ne m'intéresse pas lâche vous êtes
plus sociaux alors le livre s'appelle
comme le disent que toi masculin mon
féminin c'est aux éditions du rocher et
c'est d'un mourant érotique avant vous
dites j'ai écrit ce livre pour ne pas
mourir au lendemain du procès en appel
après la relaxe et d'humains en voyant
que je prenais encore les coûts qui est
vrai que j'ai passé quelques mois très
durs j' avais plus tellement dedes
d'avenir quoi et dans l'essex ouvert ce
membre tuméfié semble prendre naissance
voilà j'ai d'abord
c'est l'histoire d'une femme à la dérive
qui vit encore dans le souvenir du grand
amour de sa vie
le grand amour de sa vie c'est un homme
plus âgé qui l'a marqué à jamais mais
qu'il l'a jamais épousé et qui est mort
roland dumas est mort
non c'est pas je sais d'où je peux pas
caché qu effectivement l'héroïne je me
suis complètement week end est bien sûr
parce que j'avais aussi à travers à
travers celle j'avais besoin dire des
choses donc effectivement et aussi
peut-être j'ai voulu montrer une femme
une femme qui s'est battu et a pris des
sacrés pris dans la gueule et cette
femme se retrouve dans bah voilà ce
grand amour donc à coeur rien avec cet
homme elle n'a plus rien n'est
complètement algérie et elle retombe
amoureux zalla alors demain qui au
départ est très macho et on découvre
rapidement que c'est une folle tordue
non mais d'abord c'est le nord se
travestir
c'est un jeu c'est certain on a tous en
nous du masculin dit si bien qu'en même
temps on moi j'ai peut-être ces
féministes je crois que j'ai beaucoup de
masculin en moi et je me suis dit en
écrivant ce jeudi quand j'avais besoin
de vivre une histoire d'amour que je vis
pas c'est vrai je suis un peu seul
depuis sept ans et je me suis immergé là
dedans et je me suis dit voyons quel est
le genre d'homme qui pourrait me faire
me faire peut-être attendre
imaginez un homme enfin de soi d'averses
deux mois c'est à dire à la fois
masculin féminin de jouer sur les six en
moyenne un jeune homme
est allé présenter ses solutions fait
vrai en plus t'as déjà plus d'un pied
dans le 9 3 fois le 9 3 ah oui mais bon
rien à ce train là maintenant je suis
pas allé mais on dirait non je connais
personne la visite qui va connaître du
monde très bien eh ben on va y aller on
donnera une autre niche que c'est une
page 24 donc c'est un soir glace et de
pleine lune donc ici vous aide à vous
êtes avec le vieux ses avants jeu
alors elle se déshabille derrière un
four il fait très froid il fait fonction
de ta famille je venais à lui dévêtue et
voilà et alors je ne craignais plus
froids de mort qu'ils haïssaient comme
une douleur j'avançais encore j'imagine
le spectacle qui s'offrait à lui je
jubilais à un mètre de lui je m'arrêter
il s'approcha haute à sa vareuse qu'il
posa à même le sol sur l'herbe givré ces
imams 1 et l'invita et m'invite à
m'allonger j'obéis son corps recouvrit
sans aucun préliminaire il écarta mais
j'ai en tout cas c'est bien conjuguer
parce que je
devais garder karting mais j'en passe
qui ne voulait rien les cartes à ce mes
jambes tout est bien conjuguer en tout
cas
sa ceinture brutale comme un viol je
senti ça que red me pénétrer écarter les
chères comme une déchirure son désir
était violent un patient ces coups de
boutoir
ses coups de boutoir
redoublé au fond de mon ventre voilà
voilà ça c'est la mort du vieux quoi
pratiquer
vous devez tirer plus et donc
effectivement après cette aventure avec
ce set up disons d'un âge mûr
l'héroïne est complètement déboussolée
elle prête à quitter paris et là elle
rencontre le fameux francesco qui est un
riche businessman
alors il ya un truc que je supporte pas
c'est qu'il est fier de frauder le fisc
c'est une image annonce est pas une
image moi je trouve que c'est pas bien
pour les spas pierre de fautes et les
filles je dis je raconte que
qu'effectivement il est comme beaucoup
c'est à dire 20 % de français
aujourd'hui qui se demandent comment ils
vont faire et qui se délocalisent c'est
vrai que c'est dommage de l'eau 15 vous
dites la réussite qu'il faut planquer
sous peine de davy d'abus de biens
sociaux
c'est pas vrai quand sur l'argent propre
sur lequel on a payé ses impôts on peut
s'acheter tout ce qu'on veut en france
ce qui est interdit c'est un truc est un
bouillon de la société lacie sam je
crois mais si si si c'est très simple je
crois que c'est vachement bien payer des
impôts
chanter est toute ma vie que moi ça va à
quelqu'un ça aide les gens sachent et
des crèches et des hôpitaux non sérieux
ça rend service et c'est vrai qu'ils
sont heureux c'est vrai qu'ils sont
il ya des gens que
je paye des impôts et ne bénéficient pas
de certaines choses comme un citoyen
normal quoi j'appelle la police c'est
pas la même histoire quand ils viennent
fois qu'il n'appelle pas les problèmes
mais quand je lis la réussite qu'il faut
planquer sous peine de délit d'abus de
biens sociaux c'est pas vrai quand on
peut s'acheter ce qu'on veut avec
l'argent dit
aujourd'hui quelqu'un qui montrent une
entreprise qui a acquis à la force du
poignet pendant des années la montre et
sa propre entreprise à créer de l'emploi
et qui moi c'était ça arrive j'entends
ça autour de moi tous les jours et qui
achètent je sais pas j'exagère mais un
billet d'avion pour les vacances et de
la vie des nations c'est sa propre
entreprise et c'est pas non mais c'est
ça les gens s'en vont c'est qu'ils s'en
aillent cela parce que je vais vous dire
ça c'est de l'abus de bien social
effectivement s'acheter des billets
d'avion reprendre ovale en vacances sur
les frais de la société pense à certains
délits c'est un abus de bien social et
c'est interdit et c'est normal voilà
je peux donner des leçons de mode enfin
normalement les gens d'ici connaissent
pas tout ça ils demandent même pour des
petites beast ans
même pour le net positif si c'est pas
professionnel on paye avec son pote
d'accès comme si c'est vrai que ma part
aeternam plat qui s'en vont et qui sans
elle je dis cela côté moi j'ai rien
contre kielce en appuie sa vie mais qui
s'en va et on s'en fout canap la voilà
nous on reste non vraiment je suis là
voilà bon alors elle baise avec
francesco donc alors vous dites un amant
reprises
martine aubry
roberto et au marché vous qui avez écrit
le bouquin c'est pas moi
alors ils vont en vacances ensemble et
la tendance à porter des sous vêtements
féminins race est effectivement de
mettre les tests et à sang chaud là
quelle page quelle page 82 je suis en
paix ne se fait plus rageuse et secoue
la palmeraie les patientes n'est pas
plus et de jasmin sont d'enivrant
effluves le tissu s'envole parce que le
mec a mis la nuisette soit de l'emploi
dans la métaphore relie
les parfums de mer du musée de jasmin
sont des livres en effluves le tissu
s'envole découvrant sa nudité jusqu'à la
taille du mec en retombant tout en
plaquant la soie sur son ventre le pan
de la chemise s'accroche sur son sexe
tendue qu'il laisse ainsi offert commune
assure une provocation
ok
déjà associé de nathalie baye à ce stade
là on voit pas encore la bip et des
bas mais il écoute pas et je ne résiste
pas une tentation brutal nous dit que
signe de viège en cours devant lui je
m'agenouille juste voir en jeu grande
maine mes mains à travers le vêtement de
pau d'enjeu les fleurs du bout des
doigts qu'est ce que c'est agir et vite
est dessiné sous le velouté du tissu le
plus violent du mexique davantage alors
ça va jusqu'au dîner à la fin il ya un
dîner où ils arrivent maquillé mais qui
pousse à l'extrême mais pourrez vous
immerger vrai pas un mec arrive
maquiller fnac avec un porte jarretelles
parce que je trouve ça aussi
c'est ma mère
mes films à
signer des pv pour
les appels au message à la fin donc il
faut un dîner fin le mec se maquille il
met un porte jarretelles il se couche
par terre c'est des idées pour vous avec
ares avec votre canadien et l'on vous
dit ni feu même y sommes les cuisses
serré avec le sexe des mesures est
offert
c'est là monsieur drana mensurations
s'intéresse à tout ce qu
il lui dit prends moi ma chérie donc
mais qui est précédée dialogue
et alors ces moments où elle attache
magie
elle mouille son doigt pour titiller ses
salles le bout de ses seins du mec je
m'emballe sur ce pieux démesurée qui me
déchire le ventre c'est toujours
levantin sait jamais la chatte c'est
bizarre pour un livre de cuisine
régionale cela dépend même pas parce que
c'est très très chaude chez lafarge plie
en trois heures hyper chaud j'avais le
cul la mine est calciné est incrusté
d'une épaisse croûte noire
alors à jeudi à soissons
c'est
alors oui j'avais effectivement eu la
mine et helsinn est incrusté d'une
épaisse croûte morts mais qu'est ce que
c'est ça qu'il était c'est la version
bossa nova
mais s'il s'agit des casseroles
ouais
[Applaudissements]
alors oui ce qui je pleure ses
casseroles au cul donc servir eux-mêmes
et où les aveo les casseroles
c'est
alors c'est quoi que les films
sérieusement même si je sais c'est quoi
pour vous l'homme idéal sérieusement j'y
crois plus à l'homme idéal
c'est un rêve ça de j'ai un amour et je
me suis créé une histoire comme ça et en
écrivant j'ai vécu quelque chose et j'ai
oublié le reste les affaires des de la
couleur de cheveux de l'homme idéal pour
vous brun la coupe de jeu
fortement fouiller un peu imprévisible
très cul je voulais lui mais même comme
ça je voulais qu'il soit musclée puisque
ma foi surtout face à rennes pas musclé
me bat mais très musclé vague à tous les
civils et qu'il soit beau je m'en fous
qu'il ait de l'argent je m'en fous quel
bord politique voulait histoire qui fait
qu'ils soient d'aucun gordian au centre
rien du tout religion je m'en fous la
première chose que l'homme idéal dois
vous dire en se levant
au revoir
la dernière chose que l'homme il ya le
dois vous dire avant de s'endormir
je sais pas j'ai encore envie de toi à
la plus belle preuve d'amour qu'il
puisse vous donner
être là dans les coups durs ce qui
n'était pas le cas de
ce moment il s'appelait je fais plus au
fait l'homme idéal de la chaussée du
combien
les gens pour la vie ne vous a pas
épargné on va voir l'expérience que vous
en avez tiré on va faire une interview
ardilouze
[Musique]
vous avez raté combien de fois votre
permis de conduire j'ai eu du premier
coup 18 ans la tenue la plus moche que
vous ayez jamais porté sauf là on parle
pas de pas le coup du lapin
mais là le pire émissions de tv et
xavier fait
c'est pas chez vous vous avez la chance
est gentil le plus mauvais livres que
vous ayez jamais lui livre le dernier de
roland dumas a le dernier de roland
dumas oui oui vous a pas plu comment il
s'appelle je suis même plus j'oublie je
sais même plus je boive pas
c'est aussi bien il n'y avait pas études
mais un pareil le plus mauvais livres
que vous ayez écrit
le premier 1
la [ __ ] d'un coup j'aurais la personne
qui vous a fait le plus de mal on va pas
leur cité tout le temps c'est lui je
crois en page 22
[Musique]
sur le rocher
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux